-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back
to the Captain's quarters,
A little bit of housekeeping
before we start.
It has now been 136 days
since my last haircut.
While I managed to tame it
pretty well for the show.
I can't stress to you
how long it's getting.
I mean, you can probably tell
when I turn my head
to the side like that
because the back is somewhere
between a mullet
and a duck tail.
-♪ Duck Tales, whoo-ooh ♪
-But, of course, growing at long
is part of my summer project
to get James Spader's look
from the 1986 film
"Pretty in Pink."
You know, The Steff.
It's basically
a three-step process.
One, grow your hair;
two, buy a linen suit;
and three,
drink two Tabs a day.
All this is laid out
in the 1987
VHS instructional video
"The Right Steff."
Yeah, two cassettes.
And, while I would love
to show you
how long my hair is right now,
I don't want you to look at it
and think like I'm going crazy.
-Seth, you're not crazy.
-Thank you,
Talking Sea Captain Painting.
Speaking of cognitive decline...
-[ Singsong ] Segue!
-...as his poll numbers
dip to new lows,
the president is sending
more federal officers to cities
and trying to convince people
he's taking the coronavirus
pandemic seriously.
Oh, and also,
he's desperately trying
to prove to people
his brain works.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
There are lots of things
you'd like
for the president
of the United States
to be obsessed with
in a moment like this.
It'd be great, for example,
if the president was obsessed
with suppressing
the coronavirus
and setting up a rigorous system
of testing, tracing,
and isolation.
Or if the president was obsessed
with ending systemic racism
and police brutality,
or ending poverty,
or ensuring
that the tens of millions
of out-of-work Americans
and the many more
who face eviction
or loss of health insurance had
the help they need to survive.
Instead, we have a president
who's obsessed
with proving to everyone
that his brain works.
Last night, during
an interview on Fox News,
he yet again brought up
the cognitive test he took
that he supposedly aced.
You know, the one they give ya
to see if you have dementia.
-So, the last time I was
at the hospital,
probably a year ago,
a little less than a year ago,
I asked the doctor, I said,
"Is there some kind
of a cognitive test
that I could take?"
Because I've been
hearing about it
because I wanna
shut these people up.
I said to the doctor,
who was Dr. Ronny Jackson,
I said, "Is there some kind
of a test, an acuity test?"
And he said,
"There actually is,"
and he named it,
whatever it might be.
And it was 30 or 35 questions.
The first questions
are very easy.
The last questions
are much more difficult,
like a memory question.
It's like you'll go person,
woman, man,
camera,
TV.
So they say,
"Could you repeat that?"
So, I said, "Yeah.
So it's person, woman,
man, camera, TV."
"Okay. That's very good."
-Oh, my God!
He can name five objects
in his field of vision.
How does he do it?!
Send this man his
MacArthur Genius Grant.
Get Mensa on the phone.
They're gonna wanna see this.
It's like if the minds
of Einstein, Hawking, Kasparov,
and Jobs were all
rolled into one
and then stuffed inside the body
of an alcoholic walrus.
Seriously, dude, it's not a test
to see how smart you are.
It's a test to see
if you're okay.
When the referee asks a boxer
what city he's in,
it's not
[ Laughing ] a geography test.
This is a test
they give grandpas
to see if they can keep
living in their house
because God forbid
you miss a payment
on your reverse mortgage.
This dude gonna come
and take it away.
Oh, I know. I know he says
it's not a trick
to take your house,
but are you really gonna trust
a 75-year-old man
with a brown mustache?
Even the interviewer
had the face of someone
who had wandered away
from a White House tour
and just wanted
to find his family.
"Mark met the president
on our trip to D.C."
"Oh, how was that?!"
"It was bad!"
I'm pretty sure
the five things on the test
are harder than person,
woman, man, camera, TV.
Even the Sea Captain
could remember that.
-Person, woman,
man, camera, TV.
Person,
woman, man, camera, TV.
Person, woman,
man, camera, TV.
-I'm gonna test you later.
Seriously, you know who else
can look around the room
and name objects they see?
A two-year-old.
Are you sure
you didn't accidentally
see a pediatrician?
When you went in
for the appointment,
did the doctor also measure
your head size
and give you a measles shot?
[ As Trump ]
I'm not saying I aced the test,
but I did --
I did get two lollipops,
which never happens.
This is how they test people
during brain surgery
to make sure the drill
doesn't go too deep.
[ As Trump ]
Person, man, woman,
camel, camel, camel.
Okay! Okay. Let's --
Let's pull it back a little.
Also, can we go back
to this part?
-I said, "Is there some kind
of a test, an acuity test?"
And he said,
"There actually is,"
and he named it,
whatever it might be.
-"He told me the name
of the mental acuity test,
but I can't remember it."
[ As Trump ]
If memory serves, it was the
person, woman,
man, camera, TV test.
Honestly, it's not that crazy
to forget the name of the test,
unless it's a memory test
and you were planning to go
on TV and brag about acing it.
He's like a eighth grader
who tells his buddy
he has a girlfriend
and, when they ask what
a name is, he says, "I forgot."
You gotta be ready
for follow-up questions, dawg.
Don't go out of your way
to bring up a test
you claim proves
your mental acuity,
if you can't even remember
the name of it.
It's like telling someone,
"Well, I guess I'm going
to Harvard because I scored
a 1600 on my SOTs.
By the way, how you doin'
back there, Captain?
-Person, wombat,
van, sonata, E.T.
Person, wombat, van,
sonata, E.T.
Person, wombat,
van, sonata, E.T.
-[ Chuckling ] Oh,
oh, Sea Captain.
But Trump,
Trump just kept on talking.
-Okay, now, he's asking
you other questions,
other questions.
And then, 10 minutes, 15,
20 minutes later, they say,
"Remember the first question?
Not the first,
but the tenth question?
Give us that again.
Can you do that again?"
And you go,
person, woman, man,
camera, TV.
If you get it in order,
you get extra points.
They said,
"Nobody gets it in order.
It's actually not that easy,"
but, for me, it was easy.
-Person, woman,
man, camera, TV.
Aren't those the words
of a Talking Heads song?
♪ Person, woman, man,
camera, TV, hey! ♪
Those sound like the words
you can't say
on the Taboo card
for "ultrasound."
You sound like Tarzan reviewing
the season premiere
of "The Morning Show."
[ As Tarzan ]
Person,
woman, man,
camera, TV.
Tarzan give five stars.
The timing of this
psychotic episode
couldn't be any bleaker
because the media just spent
a full news cycle
fallin' for the same ruse
they've consistently been
suckered into
for the last five years --
the idea that Donald Trump
has changed his tone
on the coronavirus pandemic.
And I'm using the word ruse
very charitably, here.
Normally, a ruse would be like
an international
terrorist mastermind
constructing an elaborate plot
to lure James Bond
into his volcano lair
while he prepares to attack
the world's oil reserves
with a giant laser.
In Trump's case,
his team just gets him
to read a prepared statement
by slippin' a Valium
into his Big Mac,
the way you'd hide your dog's
arthritis pills in his kibble.
Meanwhile, secret police
are abducting
and attacking peaceful
protesters in Portland
and the president says he's
sending more federal officers
into cities across the
country, like Chicago.
So let's compare his approach
on the two issues
of protesters
and the coronavirus.
Here's Trump yesterday,
announcing his plan
to send federal
law enforcement agencies
into cities that don't
want them, don't need them,
and are actively trying
to stop them.
-Today, I'm announcing a surge
of federal law enforcement
into American communities
plagued by violent crime.
The FBI, ATF, DEA,
U.S. Marshals Service,
and Homeland Security
will together be sending
hundreds of skilled
law enforcement officers
to Chicago
to help drive down
violent crime.
There'll be a time
when they're gonna want us
to go in full-blast.
We are ready, willing, and able
to go in there with great force.
-"Go in full-blast"?
He's talkin' about American
cities like he's invading them.
"Full-blast" sounds like
a [bleep] action movie
an aspiring screenwriter
would be typin' up
in a Starbucks.
"Interior White House.
President Badass looks
at the sexy lady doctor
and says five words
she'll never forget --
person, woman, man,
camera, TV.
Her top falls off.
She asks him to stay,
but he can't,
because it's time
for full-blast!"
That's also not
how you type.
It's chilling to think of Trump
expanding the abusive
and unconstitutional tactics
we've seen in Portland
to other cities.
Trump's secret
paramilitary force
has been abducting peaceful
protesters off the streets
and stuffing them
in unmarked vans
without identifying themselves
or telling people
where they're going
or why they've been arrested.
They've shot peaceful
protesters in the head,
broken the hand of a Navy vet
who asked them
to remember their oaths,
and used tear gas and batons
to attack a peaceful
protest group
called the Wall of Moms.
-Federal agents are marching
through the streets
using war tactics --
including tear gas --
on protesters.
Last night, a group of moms,
known as the Wall of Moms,
these women in yellow shirts,
wearing helmets and goggles,
along with a group of fathers,
arrived to cheers
and then they linked to arms
to protect the protesters.
-I feel that they deploy that
so that the cameras can't see
what's really happening
and then they unlawfully
arrest moms.
Four of my moms were arrested.
-Is there anything more badass
than a wall of moms?
What bully wouldn't
back down from that?
"Where's your
lunch money, punk?"
Oh, it's right over there,
behind
the Wall of Moms.
"[ Huffing ] Huh, okay.
Well, I actually had a big
breakfast today, so, uh,
why don't you keep your money?"
I didn't think it was possible
to be more cartoonishly evil,
but then Trump decided to make
himself the anti-mom president.
What's next?
Is he gonna firebomb
an apple pie at a baseball game?
This is the clearest sign yet
that Trump has mom issues
since every other sign.
So, Trump announced a plan
to dispatch virtually
every federal law enforcement
agency at his disposal
to crack down
on peaceful protests
and invade cities that don't
even want them, full-blast!
Now, let's hear his plan
to address the raging pandemic
he's neglected for six months
at the cost of more
than 140,000 American lives.
-We are in the process
of developing a strategy
that's going to be very,
very powerful.
We've developed them
as we go along.
-You're developing
a strategy now?!
What's the rush, my man?
It's only been six months.
What have you been doin'
this whole time,
studying up
for that cognitive test?
[ As Trump ] Alright,
show me the flash cards.
I got person, woman,
man, camera, TV.
Alright, I'm good to go.
Let's take the test.
Sea Captain, by the way, do you
still remember all five things?
-KFBR392.
KFBR392.
-You're welcome.
Six people?
-Six?!
-In fact, so far, the only plan
Trump seems to have is,
once again, lying and claiming
we're close to a cure
for coronavirus,
as he has repeatedly for months.
-We're doing tremendously well
on therapeutic research
and tremendously well
on the vaccines.
And, frankly, therapeutically,
or maybe a word even
beyond that word is cure,
would be the best of all,
and we'll see what happens.
But that would be great,
if we could go into the hospital
and just cure people,
and we're at a position
we're actually able to,
to a certain extent,
with what we have right now
and we think, in a very
short period of time,
we'll be able to do that.
-Oh, yeah?
You come up with another one
of your ingenious cures again?
[ As Trump ] Okay, Fauci,
forget about the bleach.
The bleach was a bad idea.
Pence's idea.
I took the blame,
but Pence was --
Pence was pushin' the bleach.
Alright, how about this?
You fill a kiddie swimming pool
with Robitussin you just roll
around in it naked
and then,
when you're done, you
shine a flashlight up your butt.
Would that work?
Would that work, Fauci?
Also, yeah, we all agree
it would be great
if we could go into the hospital
and just cure people.
Thank you for that
searing insight.
Trump's like your super high
friend watchin' "Star Trek."
[ subdued ]
Man, that would be great,
if we could just like
teleport like from one place
to another place.
Yeah, Dave, that would be great,
but, in lieu of that,
can I order you an Uber
so you can go home?
Just step back and consider
the cruel contrast
between Trump's plan
to send secret police to cities
to crack down
on peaceful protests
and his lack of a plan
for a raging pandemic
that's killed 140,000 Americans
and left tens of millions
out of work
and many more suffering.
There's a deeper problem here.
Trump is just the most grotesque
and urgent manifestation
of that problem in our history.
Too often, our system uses
violence and incarceration
to respond to problems,
instead of just meeting the
actual needs of human beings.
That's why our police
departments have tanks,
but nearly 30 million people
don't have health insurance.
It's why we have a Department
of Homeland Security,
but 23 million Americans
face eviction.
It's why the Pentagon gets
$740 billion a year,
but there are long lines
at food banks
and an extra $600 a week
for unemployed Americans
is about to expire.
And it's why we have
secret police
who feel perfectly free
to beat up any
person, woman, and man
in front of cameras
on TV.
I did it!
I get to stay in my house!
Suck it, brown 'stache!
Anyone should be able to see
how [bleep] this is,
whether you can identify
an elephant
on a piece of paper or not.
The president is
a wannabe dictator
using paramilitary forces as his
own personal secret police.
Meanwhile, he couldn't care less
about the tens of millions
of Americans suffering
from an out-of-control pandemic
he's ignored for months.
That much should be
obvious to every...
-Person, woman, man,
camera, TV.
-Sea Captain, you're up!
-Person, woman,
man, camera, TV!
-We're not crazy!
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
So many New Yorkers are turning
to City Harvest
for help feeding their families
and they need your support
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.